From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
[SINGING] What is this thing called love? This funny thing called love? Just who can solve its mystery? Why should it make a fool of me?
[歌唱] 这个叫爱情的东西是什么？这个叫爱情的有趣东西？究竟有谁能解开它的谜团？它为什么要把我变成傻瓜？
If you listen to the lyrics to this song, I have to say, it couldn't really be stated more simply. I had you. It was happy. You left. What was that about? More than any other pop song, it just kind of throws its hands in the air and says, what the hell? Not even at the person who left, but at the very idea of love.
如果你听这首歌的歌词，我不得不说，它表达得确实不能再简单了。我曾拥有你。那时很幸福。你离开了。那到底是怎么回事？比起任何其他流行歌曲，它只是摊开双手说，这到底是什么鬼？甚至不是针对那个离开的人，而是针对“爱情”这个概念本身。
Here's Keely Smith.
这是基莉·史密斯（Keely Smith）。
[SINGING] I saw you there one wonderful day. You took my heart and threw it away. That's why I ask the Lord in heaven above-- what is this thing called love?
[歌唱] 在那个美妙的一天我遇见了你。你夺走了我的心又将它抛弃。这就是为什么我问天上的主——这个叫爱情的东西究竟是什么？
Here's a story for you. Back during World War II, an infantryman named Joe Garland fell in love-- completely, breath-stoppingly in love-- with this college student named Helen Bryan. They wrote back and forth, and when the war ended, he was eager to get married. But her parents thought that she was too young. They wanted her to finish school. They did not see what all the hurry was. He wouldn't have it.
这里有个故事给你们听。二战期间，一名叫乔·加兰（Joe Garland）的步兵爱上了一个名叫海伦·布莱恩（Helen Bryan）的大学生，爱得彻彻底底、令人窒息。他们互通书信，战争结束后，他渴望结婚。但她父母认为她太年轻了。他们想让她读完书。他们不明白为什么这么着急。但他不答应。
So he went off and made very hasty decisions, and was married within, what? To someone else. Within about six months. A great surprise, to say the least, to me.
所以他离开了，做出了非常草率的决定，在……什么？六个月内就和别人结婚了。至少对我来说，这非常令人惊讶。
I was terribly impatient. I wanted to get married. I wanted to have children. A little house in the suburbs. Do everything that we'd been deprived of, that we'd given up of, that we didn't know whether we were ever going to come back to. We've got to get in there. We've got to do it now. Everything you've got to do now. You've got to do everything now. Because you don't know whether you're going to be alive in another hour, or another day, or another year.
我当时太没耐心了。我想结婚。我想生孩子。想要郊区的一栋小房子。做我们被剥夺的一切、我们放弃的一切、我们不知道是否还有机会重来的一切。我们必须赶紧进去。我们现在就得做。所有事你现在都得做。因为你不知道自己一小时后、一天后或一年后是否还活着。
Joe gets the family he wants, has two kids. Helen marries later, has four kids. Everybody's doing great.
乔组建了他想要的家庭，有两个孩子。海伦后来结婚，有四个孩子。大家都过得很好。
30 years pass. And he's doing some research on the war years and needs to ask Helen some things. So they see each other. Sit down and talk for the first time, really since they broke up. They have lunch.
30年过去了。他在做关于战争年代的研究，需要问海伦一些事情。于是他们见了面。那是他们分手后真正意义上的第一次坐下来交谈。他们一起吃了午餐。
And I must say that I felt a remarkable sort of a glow, kind of a glow. And when I went on home, I didn't know what I was happening. I had to pull over into a rest area, and I moved up in there, and I stopped the car. And I turned off the engine. And I put my head down and I just wept. I just sobbed. I just sobbed. I wept. I was so overcome with just-- here was this person again, here was this woman again.
我必须说，我感受到了一种非凡的余温，一种光辉。当我回家时，我不知道发生了什么。我不得不把车停在休息区，我挪到那里，关掉了引擎。我低下头，只是痛哭。我只是啜泣。我只是啜泣。我哭了。我被这种感觉彻底淹没——这个人又出现在这里，这个女人又出现在这里。
They both conclude that it's something they can't ignore. They divorce their spouses, they surprise their kids, and they marry each other.
他们都认为这是无法忽视的事情。他们各自与配偶离婚，让孩子们大吃一惊，然后他们结婚了。
And now, over 20 years later, they still talk like a young couple in love. They moon over each other.
现在，20多年过去了，他们依然像一对恋爱中的年轻人那样交谈。他们相互倾慕。
It's an amazing gift to have found. And I think I could have gone through my life not knowing this was possible.
能找到这样的情感是一份了不起的礼物。我想我本可以过完一生都不知道这是可能的。
I was out doing errands today, and I came back, and I heard the piano playing. And I came in. She didn't hear me come in. And I stood in the doorway-- the piano is in there-- I just stood in the doorway listening. And I was absolutely transported. I just stood there and I watched her, playing the piano. And I thought, this is so wonderful.
今天我出去办杂事，回来时听到钢琴声。我走了进来。她没听到我进来。我站在门口——钢琴就在里面——我只是站在门口听着。我被完全带入了那个意境。我只是站在那里看着她弹钢琴。我想，这真是太美妙了。
But if you ask them, what is this thing? What is different about the love that they're feeling now compared with the love that they each felt in the decades they spent married to other people? It gets hard to describe.
但如果你问他们，这是什么东西？他们现在感受到的爱情与他们各自在与其他人结婚的几十年里感受到的爱情有什么不同？这很难描述。
The marriages, I think, were workable. But it's just the interrelatedness on so many different levels. If you can share many, many levels of interest in common, it's very, very rewarding.
我认为，之前的婚姻是可行的。但这只是在多个层面上相互关联。如果你能在许多方面有共同的兴趣，那是非常、非常有回报的。
Our reporter Sean Cole went around and around with them on this. And although these are the most articulate people in the world-- she works with the UN, he's written 22 books-- they kept talking about very prosaic things, very sensible things. Like sharing. Until finally Sean asked, isn't there anything more primal at work also? And they both said, well, of course.
我们的记者肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）就此与他们反复探讨。虽然他们是世界上最善于表达的人——她在联合国工作，他写了22本书——但他们一直在谈论非常平庸、非常理性的事情。比如分享。直到最后肖恩问，难道没有更原始的东西在起作用吗？他们都说，嗯，当然有。
Joe and I have never questioned that part of our relationship. That there's been a natural magnetism all along. You know? Good grief!
乔和我在我们关系的这一部分上从没怀疑过。一直以来都有一种自然的磁场。你知道吗？天哪！
I don't I've ever heard you put it quite that way. That's very nice. I love that. Absolutely.
我想我从未听过你这样描述。那很好。我很喜欢。绝对是这样。
Which, I suppose, just brings us back to our original question.
我想，这又把我们带回了最初的问题。
[SINGING] What is this thing called love? This funny thing called love?
[歌唱] 这个叫爱情的东西是什么？这个叫爱情的有趣东西？
Today on our program, people trying to answer this very straightforward question. Our show in three acts. Act One, Inside the Romance Industry. Act Two, The View From the Other Half. In that act, four people who've had to reconsider all their ideas about dating and love. Act Three, a real-life love story. That one from writer Sarah Vowell. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，人们试图回答这个非常直接的问题。我们的节目分为三幕。第一幕，浪漫工业内部。第二幕，来自另一半的视角。在这一幕中，四个人不得不重新思考他们关于约会和爱情的所有想法。第三幕，一个现实生活中的爱情故事。来自作家萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。请留步。
Act One. Because we live in an industrial democracy, there is a business to cater to pretty much every human need that we have. And that includes our need for romance. There are businesses in flowers and cards and diamonds and getaway spots. And there are romance novels, where an entire industry is answering the question "what is this thing called love?" for a living. Reporter Robin Epstein attended the annual convention of the Romance Writers of America at the New York Hilton. Four days, 2400 attendees.
第一幕。因为我们生活在一个工业民主社会，几乎每一种人类需求都有相应的商业来满足。这也包括我们对浪漫的需求。有鲜花、贺卡、钻石和度假胜地的生意。还有浪漫小说，整个行业都在以回答“这个叫爱情的东西是什么？”为生。记者罗宾·爱泼斯坦（Robin Epstein）参加了在纽约希尔顿酒店举行的美国浪漫作家协会年会。为期四天，2400名参加者。
Romance writers know what you think of them, and they don't give a rat's ass. One of the first conversations I had at the Romance Writers of America conference is with Jennifer Crusie and Patricia Gaffney, two of the most prominent and bestselling writers on the market today. And they wearily list the most annoying questions that are repeatedly asked by people like-- well, like people like me.
浪漫小说作家知道你们是怎么看她们的，她们一点也不在乎。我在美国浪漫作家协会会议上进行的第一次谈话是与詹妮弗·克鲁西（Jennifer Crusie）和帕特里夏·加夫尼（Patricia Gaffney）进行的，她们是当今市场上最突出、最畅销的两位作家。她们疲惫地列举了像我这样的人反复问的最令人恼火的问题。
Aren't you ashamed?
你不觉得羞耻吗？
When are you going to write a real book? Well, what does your mother think?
你什么时候写一本正经的书？嗯，你妈妈怎么想？
Why do you have those stupid covers? The knee-jerk thing is now, we'll read a sex scene on the air and everybody will laugh about it, and then will ask you how you research your sex scenes, and it's this big joke, and of course, you will laugh too. And then if you try to defend it, you're one of those feminists without a sense of humor.
为什么你们有那么蠢的封面？现在人们的第一反应就是，我们在广播里读一段性爱场景，大家都会笑，然后问你怎么研究你的性爱场景，这成了一个大笑话，当然你也会跟着笑。然后如果你试图为它辩护，你就是那种没有幽默感的女权主义者。
In my defense, I will say I was expecting to find an entirely different breed of humorless woman here-- humorless-delusionals. But instead, I immediately find myself encountering smart, funny women who are part of a business empire, one with rules and behaviors all its own.
为了我的辩护，我想说我本以为会在这里遇到一堆完全不同的缺乏幽默感的女人——无可救药的妄想狂。但相反，我立即遇到了聪明、有趣的女性，她们是一个商业帝国的一部分，一个有着自己规则和行为方式的帝国。
Welcome to RWA. I'm very excited that you all came, and I hope that today we can talk about your manuscripts, and what you have to pitch to me, and we can talk about that. OK? So-- Liz.
欢迎来到RWA。我很高兴大家能来，我希望今天我们可以谈谈你们的手稿，以及你们要向我推销的内容，我们可以谈谈这些。好的？那么——莉兹。
I am working on my tenth book. I'm going to be pitching to you my ninth book. And I've done fairly well in the contest circuit this year. I've finaled in the Dixie-- final number one-- the Dixie, the Laurie, the Molly, and--
我正在写第十本书。我要向你推销的是我的第九本书。今年我在比赛巡回赛中表现不错。我进入了Dixie的决赛——第一场决赛——还有Laurie、Molly，以及——
This smartly-dressed woman, Liz Bemis, is a web designer from Ohio, and like almost all the other conference attendees, an aspiring novelist. She's stammering through one of the most nerve-wracking parts of the convention-- the editor pitch meeting. These early morning pitchfests in the basement of the New York Hilton are what draws most of the 2400 conference attendees. This is their chance to describe what they've written to book editors in hopes of becoming a published author.
这位衣着考究的女士莉兹·贝米斯（Liz Bemis）是一位来自俄亥俄州的网页设计师，和几乎所有其他参会者一样，是一位立志成为小说家的人。她正结结巴巴地进行着会议中最让人神经紧张的部分——编辑推销会。这些在纽约希尔顿酒店地下室举行的清晨推销会是吸引2400名参会者中的大多数人的原因。这是她们描述自己作品并希望成为出版作家的机会。
At folding tables set up in conference rooms, editors from all the major publishing houses-- Avon, Kensington, Berkeley, and of course, Harlequin-- sit with their notebooks and bottles of water. The would-be authors parade in four at a time and are given 20 minutes to make their pitch before the next group enters.
在会议室摆放的折叠桌旁，来自各大出版公司——Avon、Kensington、Berkeley，当然还有Harlequin——的编辑们坐在那里，带着笔记本和水瓶。想成为作家的人四人一组列队进入，有20分钟的时间进行推销，然后下一组进入。
My next book is called Falcon's Folly . It's a--
我的下一本书叫《猎鹰的愚行》（Falcon's Folly）。它是——
Tell us what you're trying [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
告诉我们你想[听不清短语]。
OK. Single title, 100,000 words. It's the story of Jack Falcon, who's an ultra alpha DEA agent who has to abandon his testosterone-pickled ways in order to go undercover as a gay hairdresser to infiltrate a mob-led drug ring.
好的。单行本，10万字。这是杰克·猎鹰（Jack Falcon）的故事，他是一位极端的阿尔法级缉毒局特工，为了渗透进黑帮控制的毒品团伙，他不得不放弃自己那套充满雄性激素的行事方式，伪装成一名同性恋理发师。
Fun! Romantic suspense, with a little humor in it?
有趣！带有幽默感的浪漫悬疑剧？
Yes.
是的。
It's easy I understand why Liz and her fellow aspirants are here. What's less obvious is why May Chen, the sleek, young, New York editor, has gotten up early on a Saturday morning to listen to her.
我很容易理解为什么莉兹和她的同僚们会出现在这里。不太明显的是，为什么年轻、时髦的纽约编辑梅·陈（May Chen）要在周六清晨起床来听她推销。
The answer-- money. Over half the paperback fiction sold in the United States last year was romance. Over half. It's a $1.52 billion a year industry. And how about this? Romance writer Nora Roberts routinely outsells and outproduces Stephen King, Tom Clancy, and John Grisham. If basketball coaches scout public courts for future stars, this year, the basement of the New York Hilton is the romance editors' [? Roscoe ?] Park.
答案是——钱。去年美国售出的平装虚构类书籍中，超过一半是浪漫小说。超过一半。这是一个每年15.2亿美元的产业。顺便说一句？浪漫小说作家诺拉·罗伯茨（Nora Roberts）的销量和产量通常都超过斯蒂芬·金、汤姆·克兰西和约翰·格里森。如果篮球教练在公共球场发掘未来的明星，那么今年，纽约希尔顿酒店的地下室就是浪漫小说编辑的[Roscoe]公园。
When Marissa finds out that Jack is indeed straight as an arrow and intent on bringing down her beloved and innocent Uncle Mario, she devises a deviously distracting plan that will have the tough guy agent begging for mercy and eventually winning her heart.
当玛丽莎（Marissa）发现杰克实际上是直得不能再直，并且一心想要打倒她心爱且无辜的马里奥叔叔时，她设计了一个阴险且分散注意力的计划，这将使这位硬汉特工乞求怜悯，并最终赢得她的芳心。
Ooh, that sounds like a really fun idea. Sounds different. Love the gay spin. Very clever.
噢，听起来是个非常有趣的点子。听起来很特别。我很喜欢那个同性恋的转折。非常聪明。
Thank you.
谢谢。
This pitch perfectly incorporates all the elements of the typical romance novel, which is outlined by the Romance Writers of America on all its literature, and on its website, and by every representative I talked to. At the beginning of the book, there's a conflict keeping our lovers apart, and by the last page, there's a happy ending. This is what the RWA guidelines call "emotional justice." Good is rewarded. Evil is punished. Everyone gets what they deserve.
这个推销完美地包含了典型浪漫小说的所有要素，这些要素由美国浪漫作家协会在其所有文献、网站以及我交谈过的每一位代表中列出。书的开头，有一个让恋人分开的冲突，而在最后一页，有一个圆满的结局。这就是RWA准则所称的“情感正义”。善有善报。恶有恶报。每个人都得到了他们应得的。
The problem, as every editor and writer knows, is that if there's always going to be a happy ending, why would you keep reading? The difference between a good romance novel and a bad one has to do with sheer writing skill-- how well the characters are developed, the author's voice, and the complexity of the obstacles standing between the lovers and their ultimate happiness.
问题在于，正如每一位编辑和作家所知，如果结局总是圆满的，你为什么要一直读下去呢？一本好的浪漫小说和一本坏小说之间的区别在于纯粹的写作技巧——角色的塑造程度、作者的语调，以及阻碍恋人获得最终幸福的障碍的复杂性。
Outside this room, women mill around nervously awaiting their turns. Some practice their pitches, reading from index cards. Some take out pictures of their children. The RWA stations volunteers down here to make sure things keep running on time, but it's no secret that the volunteers are also here to keep anxious writers from going over the edge.
会议室外，女人们焦急地徘徊，等待着轮到自己。有些人练习推销词，从索引卡上朗读。有些人拿出孩子的照片。RWA在这里安排了志愿者，以确保会议准时进行，但大家都心知肚明，这些志愿者的存在也是为了防止焦虑的作家们崩溃。
This is volunteer Victoria Malvey. She's a tall, maternal-looking woman with a lot of blonde hair.
这是志愿者维多利亚·马尔维（Victoria Malvey）。她是一位身材高大、看起来很慈母、有着一头金色长发的女人。
I can tell you that I had one woman that I had to sit down and put her head in between her legs, because seriously, I thought that she was going to faint. She got very pale, very shaky--
我可以告诉你，我不得不让一位女士坐下来，把头埋在两腿之间，因为说真的，我以为她要晕倒了。她变得非常苍白，非常颤抖——
Victoria, it turns out, isn't just some volunteer. In fact, she doesn't need to be at this conference at all. She's already achieved what most of these 2400 writers are dreaming of.
事实证明，维多利亚不仅仅是个志愿者。事实上，她根本不需要参加这个会议。她已经实现了这2400名作家梦寐以求的事情。
You know, I've published eight books. And my first editor, I met here. One of the scary ones. And she was very businesslike. And when I was waiting to see this scary editor, there was this author, Arnette Lamb, who is a wonderful author. She has since died of brain cancer, and so it was a very sad loss for the romance community.
你知道，我出版了八本书。我的第一位编辑就是在这里遇见的。是个可怕的人。她非常公事公办。当我等着见这位可怕的编辑时，有位作家叫阿内特·兰姆（Arnette Lamb），她是一位出色的作家。她后来死于脑癌，这对浪漫小说界来说是一个非常令人悲痛的损失。
But she was from Texas, and she was big-hearted, and she was like, honey child, there's nothing to it! She's just wonderful. You'll have a great time. And it really settled something inside of me. And I can honestly tell you that I do this volunteer, two hours, in honor of Arnette, because she did this for me.
她是德克萨斯人，心胸开阔，她就像是说，亲爱的，没事的！她太棒了。你会玩得很开心的。这真的让我心里平静了下来。我可以诚实地告诉你，我做这份志愿者工作，两小时，是为了纪念阿内特，因为她也曾这样对待我。
Did that scary editor ever appear as a villain in your stories?
那位可怕的编辑有没有在你的故事里作为反派出现过？
Oh. How does one answer this and still remain politically correct?
噢。一个人怎么回答这个问题还能保持政治正确呢？
I think you just did, and I think you just didn't!
我想你刚刚做到了，而且我想你刚才没回答！
A lot of the publishing pros here turn out to be surprisingly helpful, even the ones who claim at first that they're not.
这里的许多出版专业人士结果都非常乐于助人，即使是那些起初声称自己不助人的人。
I was put on the planet to reject books. I know that.
我被派到地球上就是为了拒绝稿件的。我知道。
Kate Duffy is the editorial director at Kensington Books. She's leading one of the 168 workshops being offered at the conference. Her workshop is called Query Letter Practicum, and it's packed to overflowing with more than 200 people. A stack of query letters she's recently received on her left, she starts reading them, and mocks each as she goes.
凯特·达菲（Kate Duffy）是Kensington Books的编辑总监。她正在主持会议提供的168个工作坊之一。她的工作坊叫“查询信实践”，现场爆满，挤进了200多人。左手边是一叠她最近收到的查询信，她开始读起来，并一路嘲讽。
"Dear Ms. Duffy, Lizzie Hampton, the heroine of my light contemporary romance, work in progress, having recently lost half her body weight, heads to her childhood home, a rural corner of Michigan's Upper Peninsula. She's in town to work out the sexual kinks in her new body with old flame Phil Robbins. Phil Robbins wanted to be the proprietor of Lizzie's virginity 18 years ago." The actual proprietor would be her parents, but um. There's another word you're thinking of-- recipient, probably. [LAUGHTER] Just a guess!
“亲爱的达菲女士，莉兹·汉普顿（Lizzie Hampton），我正在创作的一部当代浪漫小说中的女主角，最近瘦了一半，回到了她的童年故居，密歇根州上半岛的一个农村角落。她回到镇上是为了与旧爱菲尔·罗宾斯（Phil Robbins）解决新身体里的性纠葛。菲尔·罗宾斯18年前就想成为莉兹贞操的拥有者。”实际的拥有者应该是她的父母，但是嗯。你脑子里想的是另一个词——接收者，大概吧。[笑声] 只是个猜测！
The cover letter goes on for several paragraphs. The bizarre plot turns continue. And Kate Duffy is not finished.
求职信延续了好几段。古怪的情节转折还在继续。而凯特·达菲还没读完。
"Trust and honesty become major hurdles for the couple. Add to that a hormone-raging 14-year-old boy, two best friends who obviously know best, and the Stanley Cup, and--"
“信任和诚实成了这对夫妇的主要障碍。再加上一个荷尔蒙激增的14岁男孩、两个显然自以为是的闺蜜，以及斯坦利杯，然后——”
And then something remarkable happens.
然后发生了一件了不起的事。
I think I probably-- because I'm a nice person-- would ask to see this. I would be curious to see if you could pull it off.
我想我大概会——因为我是个好人——要求看看这个。我很好奇你是否能写好。
This happens over and over again. A medieval historical with a nonsensical plot involving a dark duke with visions of the future and a glass-blowing heroine with a debt-ridden daddy? Send in the first three chapters. A letter full of grammatical errors telling of a paranormal romance between a demon earl and a spunky woman bent on thwarting his plan, described in several paragraphs of impenetrable plot? Send it! And then this contemporary suspense, involving an ace reporter who falls in with the Camden Thieves, a notorious gang of ne'er-do-wells.
这事一遍又一遍地发生。一个中世纪历史小说，情节荒诞，涉及一个有预见能力的黑暗公爵和一个背负巨债的玻璃吹制女主角？寄前三章来。一封充满了语法错误的信，描述了一个恶魔伯爵和一个一心挫败他计划的泼辣女人之间的超自然浪漫，用几段令人费解的情节描述？寄过来！还有这个当代悬疑小说，涉及一个王牌记者与卡姆登小偷（Camden Thieves），一群臭名昭著的二流子混在一起。
"Cold, naked, and lying flat on her back on the center of a lumpy mattress, Cathy thought her current situation couldn't get much worse. But she was wrong." [LAUGHTER] OK. "'So you're finally awake,' a slightly masculine voice murmured beside her. 'I was beginning to think they'd handcuffed me to a corpse.' The man laughed. His voice then dropped seductively." Yeah, I laugh in situations like this all the time. "'Albeit a very attractive corpse.'"
“浑身赤裸，平躺在凸凹不平的床垫中央，凯西心想她目前的处境不可能再糟了。但她错了。”[笑声] 好的。“‘你终于醒了，’一个略带男性化的声音在她耳边低语。‘我刚才还在想他们是不是把我铐在了一具尸体上。’那人笑了。他的声音随后变得充满诱惑力。”是的，我在这种情况下总是会笑。“‘虽然是一具非常有魅力的尸体。’”
OK. This is silly, and I'm not a silly woman. I don't know who the Camden Thieves are. But I think the query letter is at fault. I don't think that the author is at fault. I can't tell from this. You're giving me so many reasons to turn it down, I want to see what the hell you're up to!
好的。这很愚蠢，而我不是个愚蠢的女人。我不知道卡姆登小偷是谁。但我认为查询信本身有问题。我不认为作者有问题。我从这里看不出来。你给了我这么多拒绝你的理由，但我反而想看看你到底在搞什么鬼！
Kate asks for the first three chapters of the manuscript. What the hell is going on here? The famous authors are nice. The editors are nice. Everyone is nice. And this is the publishing business.
凯特要求看手稿的前三章。这到底是怎么回事？著名的作家很友好。编辑很友好。每个人都很友好。而这可是出版业。
I make my living as a writer. I've written for magazines. I've been on the staff of network sitcoms. And I think I speak for all professional writers when I say that this is the twilight zone. Writers are actually receiving courtesy and encouragement from industry professionals, and almost more shockingly, from one another.
我以写作为生。我为杂志写稿。我在网络情景喜剧的编剧组待过。我认为我代表了所有职业作家，我要说，这是《迷离时空》。作家们竟然真的从业内专业人士那里获得了礼遇和鼓励，更令人震惊的是，他们还从彼此那里获得了鼓励。
Where's the back-biting? The not getting your phone calls returned? The people who send you form rejection letters and don't even take the time to sign them? Where's the humiliation? Why is everybody being so kind?
背地里捅刀子的人呢？不回你电话的人呢？那些给你寄标准拒绝信甚至没时间签字的人呢？羞辱在哪里？为什么每个人都这么善良？
Well, it seems the answer to this question is twofold. Part of what's going on here has to do with the numbers. Publishing is a business that usually sees a lot of people fighting over a very small piece of pie. There can only be so many books published because, sadly, there are only so many readers, and only so much interest.
嗯，这个问题的答案似乎有两个方面。这里发生的部分事情与数字有关。出版业通常是一个很多人争抢一小块馅饼的行业。出版的书只能这么多，因为可悲的是，读者有限，兴趣也有限。
But in the romance genre, because demand is so huge, they've got a very, very big pie. A big mainstream publisher like Simon and Schuster or W.W. Norton will almost never publish an unsolicited manuscript from an unknown writer. Not so for Kate Duffy.
但在浪漫小说领域，因为需求巨大，他们拥有一个非常、非常大的馅饼。像西蒙与舒斯特（Simon and Schuster）或W.W. Norton这样的大型主流出版商几乎永远不会出版一位不知名作家的未受邀手稿。但凯特·达菲可不这么看。
We do four historicals every month, three contemporaries, four Regencies, and then we do other projects. Like, I personally am responsible for a line called Bravo, which is erotic romance. I would say every month we probably buy two or three new books from people we don't know. And that's a huge number.
我们每个月做四本历史小说、三本当代小说、四本摄政风格小说，然后我们还有其他项目。比如，我个人负责一个叫Bravo的系列，那是情色浪漫小说。我想每个月我们大概会买两三本我们不认识的人的书。这是一个巨大的数字。
But demand is just one answer to the niceness puzzle. The second becomes obvious when I enter an awards luncheon being held in one of the Hilton ballrooms. As soon as I walk in, it's stark. I'm immersed in a sea of 2000 female heads. It's like the world's largest bachelorette party.
但需求只是善良之谜的一个答案。当我进入在希尔顿宴会厅之一举行的颁奖午宴时，第二个答案变得显而易见。我一走进去，就感到无比震撼。我沉浸在2000个女性头颅的海洋中。这就像是世界上最大的单身派对。
The fact that this industry has been structured and run almost entirely by women makes a difference. Support networks abound. Virtually every town in the country has a romance writers' group, where wannabes can come to get encouragement and gentle critical feedback. And those who have succeeded make it a point to make time for others coming up. They become fans of one another.
这个行业几乎完全由女性建立和运作，这造成了很大的不同。支持网络无处不在。全国几乎每个城镇都有一个浪漫作家小组，渴望成为作家的人可以去那里获得鼓励和温和的批评建议。而那些成功的人也特意留出时间帮助后来者。她们成了彼此的粉丝。
Even the one man I ran into bought into the biological explanation for all this goodness. Literary agent Steven Axelrod.
即使是我遇到的唯一一个男人也相信这种善良背后的生物学解释。文学经纪人史蒂文·阿克塞尔罗德（Steven Axelrod）。
You know, women are just different. If you had a bunch of men and this much money on the table, it would be a free-for-all. Testosterone would be just dripping off the walls. And I think there would be vendettas, there would be-- but it would be just big and nasty. And human nature is at work here. So it's not, because it is women, all laws of human nature are suspended. But it just happens to be a very nice group of people.
你知道，女性就是不同。如果你有一群男人，桌上有这么多钱，那将是一场混战。睾丸素会从墙上滴下来。我想会有仇杀，会有——但这会是大而肮脏的。人性在这里起作用。所以，这并不是因为全是女性，人类天性的所有法则都被暂停了。但这恰好是一群非常好的人。
Over half the annoying questions reporters always ask romance writers were ones I had scribbled in my notebook before I arrived here. And I managed to invent one of my own. I thought it would be funny if I'd ask people at the conference if there was a difference between the romance in their lives and the romance in their books.
记者总是问浪漫小说作家的一半令人烦恼的问题，都是我在来到这里之前写在笔记本上的。而且我还成功发明了属于我自己的一个问题。我觉得如果我问参加会议的人，她们生活中的浪漫和书中的浪漫是否有区别，那应该会很有趣。
Appropriately, I got a blank stares. Like, honey, if you don't already know the answer to that ignorant question, I can't help you. Romance fans are aware that the romance in the book is made up, thank you very much. Romance fans read for fun, and they're just as capable of laughing at their own genre as you are.
不出所料，我得到了空白的凝视。就像在说，亲爱的，如果你还不知道那个无知问题的答案，我也帮不了你。浪漫小说的粉丝们知道书里的浪漫是虚构的，谢谢。浪漫小说的粉丝们是为了好玩而读，她们和你一样，完全有能力嘲笑自己的类型。
Here, Julia Madden and Victoria Dahl, two aspiring romance writers, talking about one of the classics in the genre with me and producer Alex Blumberg.
在这里，茱莉亚·马登（Julia Madden）和维多利亚·达尔（Victoria Dahl），两位立志成为浪漫小说作家的女性，与我和制片人亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）讨论了该类型中的经典作品之一。
To me, Savage Love is the one that I remember. And then there's The Rose and the--
对我来说，记得的是《野性之爱》（Savage Love）。然后是《玫瑰与——》
The Flame and the Flower.
《火焰与花朵》（The Flame and the Flower）。
Those are the ones where the woman was taken by force. And then she falls in love with her rapist.
那是女人被强迫的那些。然后她爱上了她的强奸犯。
Do you remember that one, I think it was [UNINTELLIGIBLE], where the woman is chained to the man for like half of the book?
你记得那个吗，我想是[听不清]，那个女人被锁在男人身边大概半本书的时间？
When you read those as a kid, did you think that's what it was going to be like? Did that actually-- Did you know that it was sort of a fantasy, or did it actually inform you?
当你小时候读这些的时候，你以为那会是什么样子？这真的——你知道那是一种幻想，还是它真的引导了你？
I don't know. I think I expected to be kind of carried away. I was very disappointed by sex, I have to say.
我不知道。我想我当时期待着被带走。我不得不说，我对性非常失望。
So was I! Isn't that odd?
我也是！那不是很奇怪吗？
That's got to be unusual.
那肯定是不寻常的。
Only little Jimmy climbed the pinnacle. Very quickly, I might add.
只有小吉米爬上了顶峰。我可以补充一点，非常快。
Really? Because mine wasn't nearly quick enough!
真的吗？因为我的一点都不快！
Still, everyone I talked to at the conference-- every reader, writer, and editor-- said she believed in romance, and believed it happens in real life. And sometimes in real life, it even follows the rules of a romance novel. One of the most emotional moments at the conference occurred at a keynote address by author Teresa Madeiros at an awards luncheon celebrating librarians.
尽管如此，我在会议上交谈过的每一个人——每一个读者、作家和编辑——都说她相信浪漫，相信它在现实生活中也会发生。有时在现实生活中，它甚至遵循浪漫小说的规则。会议上最感人的时刻之一发生在作者特蕾莎·马德罗斯（Teresa Madeiros）在庆祝图书馆员的颁奖午宴上的主题演讲中。
In closing, I'd like to share a brief story with you. They met in 1957, when he was 22 and she was 18. He was a skinny, handsome GI with a motorcycle and a devilish twinkle in his eye. She was his sister's best friend. She was beautiful, smart, and funny. He was in love.
最后，我想和你们分享一个简短的故事。他们于1957年相识，那时他22岁，她18岁。他是一个瘦弱、英俊的GI（大兵），骑着摩托车，眼睛里闪烁着顽皮的光芒。她是他在他姐姐最好的朋友。她美丽、聪明、风趣。他坠入爱河了。
They married in 1958, and three years later, while she was pregnant with what was to be their first and only child, he was transferred to Heidelberg, Germany. They lived over a bakery run by a jovial German couple named Mama and Papa Hartmann. On weekends, they would climb into his convertible MG, without so much as a change of underwear, and go racing through the countryside to explore the castles of Germany and Austria.
他们在1958年结婚，三年后，当她怀上他们第一个也是唯一的孩子时，他被调到了德国海德堡。他们住在一家面包店上面，店主是一对名叫哈特曼妈妈和爸爸的快乐德国夫妇。周末，他们会爬进他的敞篷MG跑车，连一件换洗内衣都不带，就去德国和奥地利的乡村赛车，探索那里的城堡。
The child was born in 1962. His first indication that something was wrong was when he came home from work one day to discover that his wife had given away all the furniture. Luckily a kind-hearted neighbor had taken it in and stored it in her apartment. She lost weight and stopped eating. Her speech was rapid and slurred. At times she even seemed to forget that she'd given birth to a baby.
孩子出生于1962年。他发现出问题的第一迹象是有一天他下班回家，发现妻子把所有的家具都送人了。幸运的是，一位心地善良的邻居把家具收留并存放在了她的公寓里。她体重下降，停止进食。说话含糊不清，语速很快。有时她似乎甚至忘记了自己生过孩子。
He had no choice but to seek professional help. The doctors informed him that his wife was suffering from a severe form of mental illness. It would be well over a decade before that illness was correctly diagnosed as bipolar disorder or manic-depressive illness.
他别无选择，只能寻求专业帮助。医生告诉他，他的妻子患有一种严重的精神疾病。又过了十多年，这种疾病才被正确诊断为双相情感障碍，也就是躁郁症。
He went driving along the river that dark, rainy night, at nearly 100 miles an hour, a 26-year-old soldier in a foreign country with a brand new baby and a wife facing a lifetime of torturous uncertainty. He had a choice to make. He could shuffle the baby off to be raised by relatives, and abandon his wife to the care of a German mental institution. He could drive into that river and let all of his decisions be made for him. Or he could choose to live and fight for his family.
那个阴沉、多雨的夜晚，他开着车沿着河边行驶，时速近100英里，一个26岁的士兵身处异国他乡，带着一个刚出生的孩子和一位面临一生痛苦和不确定性的妻子。他必须做出选择。他可以把孩子交给亲戚抚养，把妻子丢在德国的精神病院。他可以开车冲进那条河，让自己所有的决定由命运来定。或者他可以选择活下去，为他的家庭而战。
My parents celebrated their 44th wedding anniversary this year, because my dad meant it when he said "for better or worse, in sickness and in health." I enjoyed a relatively stable, happy childhood, and my mom's hospitalizations were kept to a minimum.
我的父母今年庆祝了结婚44周年，因为我父亲在说“无论好坏，无论生病还是健康”时是真心的。我享受了一个相对稳定、快乐的童年，我母亲的住院次数也被控制在最低限度。
My father's love is as unwavering and unconditional today as it was 44 years ago. Although my mother is now suffering from a rare brain disorder that has resulted in severe dementia, when my father visits her in the nursing home every other day, he still sees that beautiful, brilliant girl who won his heart, all those years ago.
我父亲的爱今天和44年前一样坚定、无条件。虽然我母亲现在患有一种罕见的脑部疾病，导致了严重的痴呆，但当我父亲每隔一天去疗养院看望她时，他看到的依然是多年前那个赢得了他心的美丽、聪明的女孩。
So when people ask me, "Why do you write romance?" I can only reply, "How could I not?"
所以当人们问我，“你为什么写浪漫小说？”我只能回答，“我怎么能不写呢？”
There you have it. A couple in love, an obstacle to their love, and in the end, emotional justice. Who can resist that? Why would you want to?
你看。一对相爱的人，一个阻碍他们爱情的障碍，最后，情感正义。谁能拒绝这个？你又为什么要拒绝呢？
Robin Epstein in New York.
罗宾·爱泼斯坦在纽约报道。
Coming up. If men are from Mars and women are from Venus, what do you have to learn about love when you switch from one planet to the other? Well, it turns out, a lot more than you think. In a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。如果男人来自火星，女人来自金星，当你从一个星球转换到另一个星球时，你必须学习关于爱情的什么知识？好吧，事实证明，比你想象的要多得多。稍后由芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose some theme, some subject, some question, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories. Today's program-- with Valentine's Day fast approaching-- What Is This Thing? Stories about love and people making sense of love.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，当然，我们都会选择一个主题、一个议题、一个问题，并为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目——随着情人节临近——这东西是什么？关于爱情以及人们理解爱情的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two. The View From the Other Half.
我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕。来自另一半的视角。
Sure, it's a grand generalization, but I think that it's safe to say that men approach love and relationships differently than women do. Most of them. And in the last few decades, thanks to medical science, tens of thousands of people have switched from one side of the divide to the other. When they did, among other things, they had to relearn how to find love and how to be in love from the other side of the gender line.
当然，这是一个宏大的概括，但我认为可以肯定地说，男人处理爱情和人际关系的方式与女性不同。大多数人都是这样。在过去的几十年里，多亏了医学科学，成千上万的人从鸿沟的一边跨越到了另一边。当他们这样做时，除其他事项外，他们必须重新学习如何从性别鸿沟的另一面去寻找爱情以及如何去爱。
Griffin Hansbury offers this report from the front lines. A warning to listeners that they do talk about sex in this story. Here's Griffin.
格里芬·汉斯伯里（Griffin Hansbury）带来了这一前线报道。提醒听众，在这个故事里他们谈论了性。这是格里芬。
Every so often, I get together with the guys. We grab some dinner, have a few drinks, maybe go bowling. It's typical guy time. We talk about the usual stuff. Work, women, the shape of our nipples.
每隔一段时间，我就和伙计们聚在一起。我们去吃顿饭，喝几杯，也许去打保龄球。这是典型的男人时光。我们谈论通常的东西。工作、女人、我们乳头的形状。
I guess in some ways we're not so typical. All of us were born female and were raised as girls. Today, with the help of testosterone, we all live as men. We're trans guys. Sometimes it seems that's all we have in common. If we weren't trans guys, I doubt we'd even know each other.
我想在某些方面我们并不那么典型。我们所有人都是女性出生的，都是作为女孩长大的。今天，在睾丸素的帮助下，我们都以男人的身份生活。我们是跨性别男性。有时看起来这就是我们的共同点。如果我们不是跨性别男性，我怀疑我们甚至不会认识对方。
Romance, on the other side of the great gender divide, has meant different things for each of us. One guy lives with his wife in the 'burbs. One plays the field. Another is still trying to find the field. And a couple of us-- myself included-- are in long-term relationships, hoping they'll last a lifetime. But all of us are still finding our way.
浪漫，在伟大性别鸿沟的另一边，对我们每个人来说意味着不同的事情。一个人和他的妻子住在郊区。一个人在四处猎艳。另一个人仍在试图找到那个领域。而我们中的几个人——包括我在内——正处于长期关系中，希望它们能持续一生。但我们都在寻找自己的方向。
After transition, it became harder for me and my friend Ray to find women to date. It wasn't always like that. Back in college, we were both known as BDOCs-- Big Dykes On Campus. Here's Ray.
变性后，我和我的朋友雷（Ray）变得更难找到约会的女性。以前并不总是这样。在大学里，我们俩都被称为BDOC——校园里的“大拉拉”。这是雷。
Basically, I was the go-to lesbian, I think. I probably slept with a good portion of the women on campus. And honestly, it was never like having to look for a date. I never had any trouble, as a lesbian, meeting women. Ever.
基本上，我想我是个“御用”拉拉。我可能和校园里相当大一部分女性睡过。老实说，作为拉拉，我从没觉得要找人约会是个困难。从来没有。
Looking at Ray, you can't see a trace of the female he once was. He's got a T-shirt that says "Italian Stallion," a goatee on his handsome face, and impressive biceps that he's built up with weight lifting and testosterone. Testosterone puts hair on your chest, lowers your voice, and basically turns you into a teenage boy. Giddy and girl crazy, staring in the mirror every five minutes to see if those sideburns are coming in yet.
看着雷，你看不出他曾经是女性的痕迹。他穿着一件印着“意大利种马”的T恤，英俊的脸上留着山羊胡，还有通过举重和睾丸素练就的令人印象深刻的二头肌。睾丸素让你的胸部长毛，声音变低，基本上让你变成一个青少年男孩。晕头转向且对女孩疯狂，每五分钟盯着镜子看那些鬓角长出来没有。
Ray looked forward to being a single guy for the first time in his life-- until it actually happened.
雷期待着第一次作为单身男人生活——直到它真正发生。
It ended up being really kind of scary and sucky versus exciting. You know? Appearance-wise, sure, it works for me to go into a straight club. But would I know what to do once I got there?
结果这比起兴奋，反而更让人觉得恐怖和糟糕。你知道吗？在外表上，当然，我进直男俱乐部没问题。但一旦进去，我知道该做什么吗？
Being socialized as a female, I just feel like I, and many of us, were never really taught how to pick somebody up. You know, I think staring at somebody briefly and looking away was like the big signal that you were interested in somebody. And now seeing the way men are socialized, and how very much men make eye contact, and are able to approach people. I was never socialized that way.
作为女性长大的，我只是觉得我，以及我们中的许多人，从没真正学会如何去“泡”一个人。你知道，我觉得简短地盯着一个人看然后再转过头，就像是对某人感兴趣的重大信号。而现在看到男人社会化的方式，以及男人是多么地擅长眼神接触，并且能够接近别人。我从未那样被社会化过。
Who was our target audience now? Who are we supposed to be trying to date? It doesn't seem to make a whole lot of sense to try to date lesbians, because generally speaking, they're going to want to be with women.
我们现在的目标受众是谁？我们应该尝试去和谁约会？尝试和拉拉约会似乎没什么意义，因为总的来说，她们会想要和女人在一起。
And yet, dating 100% heterosexual, never given it a second thought women, seems to have its own treachery. Because there were some, you know, body differences when you're transsexual. And not knowing if they'll run screaming from the room or like pull a Crying Game-- who wants to expose themselves to that?
然而，和100%异性恋、从未对此有过二次想法的女性约会，似乎也有其自身的风险。因为当你跨性别时，身体会有一些差异。不知道她们是会尖叫着跑出房间还是像《哭泣游戏》那样——谁想让自己暴露在那样的情境中？
When you hang out with a bunch of transsexuals and you talk about dating, eventually you get to The Crying Game. When we talk about The Crying Game, what we're really talking about is that intimate scene where the trans woman opens her robe to reveal the truth and the guy responds by puking in the bathroom.
当你和一群跨性别者混在一起谈论约会时，最终你会谈到《哭泣游戏》。当我们谈论《哭泣游戏》时，我们真正谈论的是那个私密的场景，跨性别女性打开长袍展示真相，而那个男人的反应是在洗手间呕吐。
For most people, it's a surprise ending, nothing more. But for me, and for many trans people, it's the ending we fear the most-- even for our happiest and most fantastic stories.
对大多数人来说，这只是个惊人的结局，仅此而已。但对我，以及许多跨性别者来说，这是我们最害怕的结局——即使是在我们最快乐、最美妙的故事中也是如此。
My friends and I, a group of other trans men and myself, were going away for a weekend down to the Jersey Shore. And on a particular night, we happened to be driving down to Atlantic City. And we were in an SUV. I guess there were about four or five of us. And we were all pretty early in our transition, but we all sort of looked male. Like average, younger than our age, men.
我和我的朋友们，一群其他的跨性别男性，要去泽西海岸度周末。那天晚上，我们碰巧开车去大西洋城。我们在一家SUV里。我想大概有四五个人。我们都处于变性的早期阶段，但我们看起来都像男性。像普通的、比实际年龄年轻的男性。
And so this carload of girls is kind of driving by the SUV, and we're up a little higher, so we have a good view of everything. And they see us and they start waving, and doing that thing that whatever 19-year-old girls do. Waving and being flirtatious. And, you know, our interest was kind of piqued.
所以这车女孩开过我们的SUV，我们位置高一点，所以看得很清楚。她们看到我们，就开始挥手，做那些19岁女孩会做的事情。挥手和调情。你知道，我们的兴趣被勾起了。
And then suddenly, one of them like pops out of the sunroof and lifts up her shirt and flashes us her chest. And so now we're like, really shocked and screaming, and like, oh my God, and we're clapping and egging her on.
突然，其中一个从天窗探出头来，掀起衬衫，向我们展示她的胸部。所以现在我们真的很震惊、尖叫，就像，噢，天哪，我们鼓掌并怂恿她。
And the next thing you know, the passenger in the front seat decides to grab the girl who's driving and start kissing her for us. Like, watch this. And then starts, you know, kissing this other girl. I guess that whole, girl kissing girl, turns guys on.
接下来你知道的，前排乘客决定抓住开车的女孩开始为我们接吻。就像，看着这个。然后开始，你知道，亲吻那个女孩。我猜那个女孩亲吻女孩的事情，会让男人兴奋。
So we were just really egging them on and having a great time. And we were just all sort of looking at each other, like we couldn't believe it was happening. You know? Like, this is us. This is not the car past us. They're really looking at us.
所以我们真的很怂恿她们，玩得很开心。我们只是都看着对方，仿佛不敢相信这一切正在发生。你知道吗？就像，这是我们。这不是经过我们的车。她们真的在看我们。
And so this went on and on, and it got the point where it was happening for like a half an hour that we were alongside of them. And so they pulled up alongside of us eventually. We opened our window. They opened their window. I guess we had just gotten out of a toll booth. And one of them said, where are you guys going? And we said, oh, we're going to Atlantic City. They said, oh, we are too, we are too! What are you guys doing there? We're like, oh, we're going to gamble and stuff. They're like, you want to come hang out with us? And we said, sure! Let's go, let's go!
所以这一切持续了很长时间，到了大概持续了半个小时我们并排行驶的时候。所以她们最终并排停在我们旁边。我们打开窗户。她们打开窗户。我想我们刚过完收费站。其中一个说，你们要去哪？我们说，哦，我们要去大西洋城。她们说，哦，我们也去，我们也去！你们去那干嘛？我们说，哦，我们要去赌博什么的。她们说，你们想来和我们一起玩吗？我们说，好啊！走吧，走吧！
And suddenly she says, hey, we're going to go skinny dipping. Do you want to come? And suddenly we just all look at each other and our faces just drop. You know? Just drop. Because we suddenly realize that this whole fantasy thing that was being created couldn't really exist without the reality of who we are. We were all very early in transition. Some of us had had some surgery. Some of us hadn't. And there is no way we were going to be naked without them knowing our history.
突然她说，嘿，我们要去裸泳。你们想来吗？突然我们所有人都看着对方，脸色都垮了下来。你知道吗？直接垮了。因为我们突然意识到，整个被创造出来的奇幻场景，如果没有我们作为真实自我的存在，就无法真正成立。我们都处于变性的早期阶段。我们中的一些人做过手术。一些人没做过。没有办法我们能在她们不知道我们过去的情况下赤身裸体。
So we just kind of like waved and smiled and didn't really answer, and they went away. But I think we all remember that as a really, like, just-- as silly and immature as it sounds-- it was really defining. It was a moment that we had missed. And we had a chance to kind of live that for a moment. Just a moment. But that was enough. You know?
所以我们只是挥了挥手、笑了笑，并没有真正回答，她们就离开了。但我认为我们都记得那是一个真的，哪怕听起来很愚蠢和幼稚——那确实是决定性的。那是我们错过的一个瞬间。我们曾经有机会活在那一刻里。哪怕只有一瞬间。但这足够了。你知道吗？
I remember having some sadness, but I remember being a lot more excited about the fact that that happened. You know? There was a moment where, because we were a collective together, because there were four or five of us, I had a sadness for us. Of like, this fate that we share, that there is something exceptional. That there is something. We are an exception to most men in the world.
我记得有一些悲伤，但我记得对于那件事发生了感到更加兴奋。你知道吗？有那么一刻，因为我们是一个集体，因为我们有四五个人，我为我们感到悲伤。就像，我们共有的这种命运，那种特殊之处。就像，有一些东西。我们是世界上大多数男人的例外。
I forget that, though. On a daily basis, I do forget that. After a while, you just live as a man, and you forget that you are such an exception. And so there are moments that point it out, and sometimes, they are harder than others.
不过，我确实忘了这一点。在日常生活中，我确实忘了。过了一段时间，你只是作为男人生活，你就忘了自己是个例外。所以会有一些时刻指出这一点，有时，这些时刻比其他时刻更艰难。
It's so hard to break the news to a woman about your past, that Ray and I have almost never risked it.
向一个女人坦白你的过去太难了，以至于我和雷几乎从不敢冒险。
True story, though. I was on a blind date with this woman. We had lunch. We'd been talking for hours. And I was just getting ready to come out with my big revelation. And she says to me, there's something I have to tell you. She looks kind of nervous and she says, up until now, I used to date women. Does that bother you?
真实的故事。我和这个女人相亲。我们吃了午饭。我们谈了好几个小时。我正准备说出我的重大揭露。她说，我有件事要告诉你。她看起来有点紧张，她说，直到现在，我过去常和女人约会。这困扰你吗？
I said, no. It doesn't bother me. Because up until now, I used to be a woman. We never had a second date.
我说，不。这不困扰我。因为直到现在，我过去曾是个女人。我们再也没约会过第二次。
My friend Ethan doesn't have these problems. Unlike the rest of us, he's had absolutely no fear of The Crying Game. When I ask him how he can be so confident, he just shrugs his shoulders. It never occurs to him to be afraid.
我的朋友伊桑（Ethan）没有这些问题。不像我们其他人，他完全没有对《哭泣游戏》的恐惧。当我问他为什么能这么自信时，他只是耸耸肩。他从来没想过要害怕。
An easy-going and good-looking, dance club DJ with mutton-chop sideburns and armloads of tattoos, Ethan's a babe magnet. In his glove compartment, he keeps a spare toothbrush and a clean pair of boxer shorts. That's confidence. Ethan can pick up a woman in a bar, tell her about his past, and go home with her the same night-- no big deal. Here's an example of the kind of story he tells.
一个随和、好看、留着羊排鬓角、双臂纹身的舞厅DJ，伊桑是个“宝贝磁铁”。他在手套箱里放着一把备用牙刷和一条干净的平角内裤。那就是自信。伊桑可以在酒吧泡到一个女人，告诉她自己的过去，然后带她回家——没什么大不了的。这是他讲的故事的一个例子。
I went to an all-girls high school. So I went back to my 10-year reunion, and I was like one guy with like 15 women, and it was so much fun. And I tell you, I just had the best time.
我上的是一所全女子高中。所以我回到了我的10年同学聚会，我就像是15个女人中间的一个男人，那真是太有趣了。我告诉你，我玩得真是太开心了。
Well, first of all, in that night-- let's see-- just like there was such debauchery. It was ridiculous. We were like kids. We were playing spin the bottle, truth or dare. I was like, oh, no way! Holy cow, this is crazy.
嗯，首先，那天晚上——让我看看——简直太堕落了。太荒唐了。我们就像孩子一样。我们在玩转瓶子，真心话大冒险。我当时想，噢，没门！天哪，这太疯狂了。
But even Ethan encounters dating difficulties. He's always dated women casually, but it's different now that he's a guy. When he doesn't call someone for a week, or when he's busy with someone else on a Saturday night, he now gets angry emails from unhappy women. The old rules he used to play by have changed.
但即使是伊桑也遇到了约会困难。他一直随随便便地和女人约会，但他现在作为男人就不同了。当他一周没打电话给某人，或者周六晚上忙着和别人在一起时，他现在会收到不快乐女人的愤怒邮件。他以前玩的旧规则已经变了。
Previously, it was sort of, there was-- you know, if I was dating a straight woman who is used to dating men, because I was a woman, I think she would feel safe. Like, she sort of felt like, well, there's safety here. I don't have to play games, because this is my equal. This is my friend. This is my partner. This is-- you know, feeling like we're on the same playing field. Everything's level. And I feel like that's definitely not the case, or not the approach that's taken when you're seen as a man.
以前，这就好像是——你知道，如果我在和一个习惯和男人约会的直女约会，因为我是个女人，我觉得她会感到安全。就像，她有点觉得，嗯，这里有安全性。我不必玩游戏，因为这是我的平等对象。这是我的朋友。这是我的伴侣。这是——你知道，感觉我们在同一个赛道上。一切都是平等的。我觉得这绝对不是事实，也不是被视为男人时采取的方法。
We've all had to adjust to these strange new codes of behavior. Before I looked like a man, I could talk to women about how I liked going to strip clubs, and that made me cool and edgy. Now it just makes me a jerk.
我们所有人都不得不适应这些奇怪的新行为准则。在我看起来像男人之前，我可以和女人谈论我喜欢去脱衣舞俱乐部，那让我看起来很酷很前卫。现在这只会让我看起来是个混蛋。
My friend Nate is a different story than the rest of us. Most of the guys in the group always wanted to be men and were attracted to women. Nate wanted to be a man, but he was attracted to other men.
我的朋友内特（Nate）和我们其他人不同。小组里的大多数男人一直想成为男人，并且被女人吸引。内特想成为男人，但他被其他男人吸引。
One common response I get when I tell people I'm transgender is they say, well, why didn't you just stay a girl? If you're attracted to men, why not just be a straight woman? As if that's all it takes. It's just being attracted to men.
当我告诉人们我是跨性别者时，我得到的一个共同反应是，嗯，你为什么不直接当个女孩呢？如果你被男人吸引，为什么不直接当个直女呢？好像就这么简单。只是被男人吸引。
My entire persona. Like, my personality, everything about me is male. I mean, a straight woman, I may in fact be attracted to-- both be attracted to, say, Antonio Banderas, but I think that the ways in which we-- everything else is different. Who we are is different. Very different.
我整个人。就像，我的个性，关于我的一切都是男性的。我的意思是，直女，我可能实际上被吸引——我们都可能被安东尼奥·班德拉斯吸引，但我认为我们处理——其他一切都不同。我们是谁不同。非常不同。
It is a little hard to understand, I know. But today Nate is a cute gay man with close-cropped hair, stylish glasses, and a trim, compact build, looking for another cute gay man to date.
我知道这有点难理解。但今天内特是一个可爱的男同性恋，留着修剪整齐的短发，戴着时髦的眼镜，体型紧凑，正在寻找另一个可爱的男同性恋约会。
In his search for love, Nate had a harder time than the rest of us figuring out his target audience. Like everyone else, he couldn't understand how a female-bodied person could be a gay man, and he went through a long process of elimination. He knew he wasn't a straight girl. He felt like a boy. Maybe he was a lesbian.
在寻找爱情的过程中，内特比我们其他人更难弄清楚他的目标受众。和其他人一样，他不明白一个女性身体的人怎么能成为男同性恋，他经历了一个漫长的排除过程。他知道他不是直女。他感觉自己像个男孩。也许他是拉拉。
I made every possible effort. I bought all the folk music albums. I was good at the cultural stuff. I wore sandals. I went to Mexico and studied, you know, women and their struggles in Latin America. I own every Indigo Girls album ever made. Every Ani DiFranco album. Gosh. I became a vegetarian, had a heavily soy-based diet. I mean really! I'm not kidding. It was actually being a woman attracted to women that was the hard part.
我尽了最大努力。我买了所有的民谣专辑。我在文化方面表现不错。我穿凉鞋。我去了墨西哥学习，你知道，女性及其在拉丁美洲的挣扎。我拥有Indigo Girls发行过的每一张专辑。Ani DiFranco的每一张专辑。天哪。我成了素食者，饮食以大豆为主。我是说真的！我没开玩笑。其实作为一个被女人吸引的女人才是最难的部分。
I even went through a man-hating stage. Not that all lesbians did that. I mean, certainly, this was my attempt at being a lesbian. That came more from my resentment of everything men had that I wanted.
我甚至经历了一个讨厌男人的阶段。并不是说所有的拉拉都那样。我的意思是，当然，这是我试图成为拉拉的尝试。那更多来自我对男人所拥有的我想要的一切的怨恨。
I would just look at men on the subway and just feel so resentful. I felt like men just took for granted the fact that they looked like men. I'd look at these men just sitting there on the subway. I was like, God, if I were them, I would just be jumping up and down, jumping for joy. And they're just walking around, these schlumpy men, you know? Just all these different men, with their male chests and male genitalia and wearing a tie to work. Just not even appreciating it.
我当时只是看着地铁上的男人，感到非常怨恨。我觉得男人只是理所当然地认为他们看起来像男人。我看着这些坐在地铁上的男人。我当时想，上帝，如果我是他们，我会只是上下跳跃，欢呼雀跃。而他们只是在走来走去，这些邋遢的男人，你知道吗？只是所有这些不同的男人，有男人的胸部和男人的生殖器，系着领带上班。甚至一点都不珍惜。
After the lesbian experiment failed, Nate finally realized what he had to do. He got chest surgery and started taking testosterone. Nate liked to joke that he's the only person he knows it's been L, G, B, and T-- the common shorthand for lesbian, gay, bisexual, and transgender. And for every letter, there's been a coming out to his parents. Think about that for a second.
拉拉实验失败后，内特终于意识到他该做什么。他做了胸部手术，开始服用睾丸素。内特喜欢开玩笑说他是他认识的唯一一个经历过L、G、B和T的人——拉拉、男同性恋、双性恋和跨性别的常用缩写。而且每一个字母，都有一个对他父母的“出柜”。想想这个。
But so far, all his hard work hasn't helped his love life much. Meeting men isn't too difficult for Nate. He's got a couple ads online, and gets regular responses. He goes out on a lot of first dates, but there aren't a lot of seconds.
但到目前为止，他所有的努力对他的爱情生活没什么帮助。结识男人对内特来说并不太难。他在网上有几个广告，并得到常规回复。他有很多次第一次约会，但没有多少第二次。
I haven't had anyone, you know, throw up like in The Crying Game. So I guess that's a good thing. But the best one was, I met this guy through a friend of a friend, and we met up, and walked around the city. And we ended up at Hudson River Park and we watched the fireworks at the end of the Gay Pride Parade. There's some beautiful fireworks at the end of the parade. And I don't know. I guess you could say it was romantic.
我还没遇到像《哭泣游戏》里那样呕吐的人。所以我猜这是件好事。但最好的一次是，我通过朋友的朋友认识了一个人，我们见面后，在城市里走来走去。最后我们在哈德逊河公园看了同性恋骄傲游行结束时的烟花。游行结束时有美丽的烟花。我不知道。我猜你可以说这很浪漫。
We had a subsequent date, and at the very end of the date, I said, you know, there's something that's kind of hard to tell you, but I feel like it's time to let you know. And he said, what, you're transsexual? And he was joking. He was trying to come up with the weirdest thing that he could think of, just to make me feel better.
我们后来又约会了，在约会结束时，我说，你知道，有件事很难告诉你，但我觉得是时候让你知道了。他说，怎么，你是变性人？他是在开玩笑。他想试图说出他能想到的最奇怪的事情，只是为了让我感觉好一点。
And I wish I could just go out there and date whoever I wanted, and they didn't have to be this incredibly open-minded person, you know? My therapist the other day said, he actually said, we'd be both [BLEEP] ourselves if we didn't say that it's going to be incredibly difficult for you to find a life partner. And I'm thinking, God, I'm paying you for this?
我真希望我能随心所欲地出去约会任何人，他们不必是一个思想极其开放的人，你知道吗？我的心理医生前几天说，他实际上说，如果我们不说你找到生活伴侣会非常困难，那就是在自欺欺人。我在想，上帝，我付钱给你就是为了听这个？
Still, Nate keeps trying. He's cute and funny, and he's playing the game, which is more than he ever did before transition, when he couldn't even get off the bench. I'm sure it's just a matter of time before Nate finds someone to curl up with on the couch to watch Will and Grace.
尽管如此，内特一直在尝试。他可爱又风趣，他在玩这个游戏，这比他在变性前他甚至不能离开板凳的时候做的多多了。我相信内特找到人一起蜷缩在沙发上看《威尔和格蕾丝》只是时间问题。
So you spend all this time waiting for love to come along, worrying that it never will, and wondering what you'll do with it now that you've got this new body. What happens then when love finally shows up?
所以你花所有的时间等待爱情降临，担心它永远不会来，并想知道既然你有了这个新身体，你会拿它做什么。当爱情终于出现时，会发生什么呢？
Ray, the Italian Stallion from earlier in my story, has been with his girlfriend Amy for nearly a year. She knew he was trans right from the start, because Ray's roommate introduced them. Ray fell for Amy the moment he first saw her, and she fell for him. But Amy had never dated a trans man and Ray had never dated a straight woman, so nobody made a move. Six months passed with no contact at all.
我故事里早先提到的“意大利种马”雷，已经和他的女朋友艾米（Amy）在一起快一年了。她从一开始就知道他是跨性别者，因为雷的室友介绍了他们。雷在第一次看到艾米时就爱上了她，她也爱上了他。但艾米从未和跨性别男性约会过，雷也从未和直女约会过，所以没人采取行动。六个月过去了，没有任何接触。
Finally, it was Amy who got things going. She dropped Ray an email and their courtship began at a glacial pace, including a long series of platonic lunches and dinners.
最后，是艾米开始了行动。她给雷发了一封电子邮件，他们的求爱以缓慢的速度开始了，包括一系列长时间的柏拉图式的午餐和晚餐。
Well, it got to the point where it was ridiculous. Like, we went out to dinner, we heard this band, and we were sitting really close, sort of-- it was like a Moroccan restaurant-- we were sitting on pillows on the floor. And we were sitting there, and it was sort of like-- you were talking, but both of us were sort of like, kiss each other. In, I think, both of our minds, it was like, somebody has to kiss somebody. Sort of like you're talking, but then you lose track of what you're saying, because you can't even pay attention to it, because you're like, we've got to kiss, we've got to kiss. And we didn't.
好吧，这到了荒唐的地步。就像，我们去吃晚餐，听了这个乐队，我们坐得非常近，有点——这是一家摩洛哥餐厅——我们坐在地上的垫子上。我们坐在那里，就像——你在说话，但我们俩都觉得，亲吻彼此。我想，在我们两人的脑海里，都是——有人必须亲吻某人。就像你在说话，但随后你失去了你正在说的轨迹，因为你甚至无法注意它，因为你在想，我们必须亲吻，我们必须亲吻。但我们没吻。
Finally, one night after a movie, Ray walked Amy home, and they lost themselves in conversation for 70 long blocks.
最后，看完电影的一个晚上，雷送艾米回家，他们在谈话中迷失了70个街区。
It's miles, yeah. It was definitely miles. And we weren't in walking shoes, and we were carrying bags, and it was nighttime, and there was a million different reasons why we should have just taken a cab or the subway, but we did not.
那是英里，是的。绝对是英里。我们没穿走路的鞋子，我们提着包，那是晚上，有几百万种理由为什么我们应该坐出租车或地铁，但我们没坐。
And she did say that she wasn't really sure, like, completely how she felt about the trans thing. And then at the same moment, or like the next moment, she'd be very physical with me. So I was getting these two different signals.
她确实说她不是很确定，比如，完全对跨性别这件事的感觉。然后就在那一刻，或者就像下一刻，她会对我很亲昵。所以我收到了这两个不同的信号。
When we took that 70-block walk and we ended up at my house, I thought, well maybe he'll kiss me goodnight. And then he kind of hugged me goodnight, and I was a little disappointed.
当我们走了那70个街区，最后到了我家时，我想，也许他会吻我晚安。然后他有点拥抱我晚安，我有点失望。
But it was my choice. Like, I was the one who went, you know, saying, let's be friends. And then I don't know why I was disappointed that he didn't kiss me. I couldn't-- I was sort of confused-- and I couldn't really figure it out, what I was doing. What I was doing. I couldn't figure out what I was doing.
但这是我的选择。就像，我是那个说，你知道，让我们成为朋友的人。然后我不知道为什么我对没吻我感到失望。我不能——我有点困惑——我无法真正弄明白，我在做什么。我在做什么。我无法弄明白我在做什么。
In retrospect, what do you think you were doing?
回顾过去，你认为你在做什么？
Because I liked him so much, I wanted to make sure that if we-- I just knew that every step I was taking was like a step I couldn't turn back.
因为我太喜欢他了，我想确保如果我们要——我知道我走的每一步都像是无法回头的一步。
Romance is about overcoming obstacles. And in a way, Ray and Amy's story is the perfect plot for a romance novel. Girl meets boy. Girl grapples with the fact that boy used to be a girl. Girl falls in love with boy. I'm surprised Harlequin hasn't jumped on this one yet.
浪漫就是克服障碍。在某种程度上，雷和艾米的故事是浪漫小说的完美情节。女孩遇到男孩。女孩纠结于男孩曾经是女孩的事实。女孩爱上男孩。我很惊讶Harlequin还没用这个题材。
I like to think that trans men give you the best of both worlds. I hear so many women say things like, I wish my gay best friend were straight for like a day. Well, that's us. We're your gay best friend, and we want to date you. We want to go shopping and take dance lessons with you. It's not a bad deal when you think about it.
我喜欢认为跨性别男性给你两全其美。我听到很多女性说这样的话，我希望我的男同闺蜜能直一天。好吧，那便是我们。我们是你的男同闺蜜，我们要和你约会。我们想和你一起购物和上舞蹈课。当你想到它时，这并不是一笔坏交易。
But of course, even with all the good stuff, no trans man is perfect. There is one big thing missing. Or maybe it's not so big.
但当然，即使有所有的好东西，没有跨性别男性是完美的。有一件大事缺失了。或者也许它并没有那么大。
So what everybody really wants to know is what our sex life is like. And it's weird, because when I talk about it, I feel like a science experiment.
所以每个人真正想知道的是我们的性生活是什么样的。这很奇怪，因为当我谈论它时，我觉得像个科学实验。
I mean, I get really sick of that question when people ask me, and here I am asking you about it. And as a trans man, I think that that's a question that-- an answer that is something that I really want to know, and that I'm afraid of. Like, do you miss having a penis? I think it's on every trans man's mind too.
我的意思是，当人们问我那个问题时，我感到很厌烦，而现在我正问你。作为跨性别男性，我认为那是一个问题——一个我真正想知道、但我又害怕的答案。就像，你怀念有阴茎吗？我想这也在每个跨性别男性的脑海里。
It's a difficult question to answer. Because you love this person, and in some ways, it feels-- you know, modern technology has made it possible for it to be very similar. And you know, sometimes I think-- I don't necessarily say I would miss a penis. I missed an ease. I miss a little bit more simplicity. I miss the simplicity of it, I think. Not the actual body part.
这是一个很难回答的问题。因为你爱这个人，在某些方面，它感觉——你知道，现代技术已经使它可能变得非常相似。你知道，有时我想——我不一定说我会怀念阴茎。我怀念一种轻松。我怀念一点点简单。我想我怀念它的简单。而不是身体部位本身。
If you passed them on the street, you wouldn't know that Ray and Amy were anything more than ordinary. The only way you would know is if they told you.
如果你在街上经过他们，你不会知道雷和艾米除了平凡之外有什么特别。你唯一知道的方法就是他们告诉你。
Coming out is something Amy never had to do until she fell in love with Ray. Now all of a sudden she's co-starring in The Crying Game, and people look at her differently too.
“出柜”是艾米在爱上雷之前从未做过的事情。现在突然间她成了《哭泣游戏》的联合主演，人们看待她的方式也不同了。
Half of your listeners, they're wondering what I'm like. They're wondering what I look like. Am I attractive enough? Couldn't I go to a bar in New York and pick out a nice single Jewish man? And I'm definitely the kind of girl who'd go to a bar. I look like every other cute girl New Yorker who wears expensive clothes and pointy-toed shoes. Like, I look like everybody else. And I'm choosing this. Like, I've chosen this person.
你的一半听众都在想我长什么样。她们在想我的样子。我够吸引人吗？我不能去纽约的一家酒吧挑个不错的单身犹太男人吗？我绝对是那种会去酒吧的女孩。我看起来像每个其他可爱的纽约女孩，穿昂贵的衣服和尖头鞋。就像，我看起来像其他人。而我选择了这个。就像，我选择了这个人。
I fell in love with this amazing man. And all my friends who know him are jealous. Like they wish that they could meet a Ray.
我爱上了一个了不起的男人。所有认识他的朋友都很嫉妒。就像她们希望自己能遇见一个雷。
Transition itself is in some ways the most romantic undertaking of all. It's an idealistic adventure, extravagant and kind of unreal. You commit yourself to a feeling early on, a dream you've had all your life, and then you do it, believing all the while that the impossible can be made possible, that the great divide can be crossed. It's a total leap of faith, like falling in love. You don't know what will happen when you get to the other side, but you go there anyway.
变性本身在某种程度上是最浪漫的事业。这是一种理想主义的冒险，铺张且有点不真实。你早早地把自己投入一种感觉中，一个你一生都有的梦想，然后你做了，始终相信不可能的事可以变得可能，那伟大的鸿沟可以跨越。这是一个完全的信念飞跃，就像坠入爱河。你不知道当你到达另一边时会发生什么，但你还是去了。
Griffin Hansbury.
格里芬·汉斯伯里。
Act Three. A Love Story.
第三幕。一个爱情故事。
Well, we wanted to end our show today with a love story. A little real-life fable with an answer to the question, what is this thing called love? Sarah Vowell believes that she has just the one.
好吧，我们今天想以一个爱情故事结束我们的节目。一个小小的现实生活中的寓言，回答了那个问题，这个叫爱情的东西是什么？萨拉·沃威尔相信她正好有这么一个故事。
The marriage of Johnny Cash and June Carter Cash is the greatest love story of the 20th century. The first time Johnny saw June, he was on his high school senior class trip to Nashville, and she was on stage at the Grand Ole Opry, singing with her famous relatives, the Carter family, and cracking jokes with Ernest Tubb.
约翰尼·卡什（Johnny Cash）和琼·卡特·卡什（June Carter Cash）的婚姻是20世纪最伟大的爱情故事。约翰尼第一次见到琼时，他在高三班级旅行到纳什维尔，而她正在大奥普里剧院的舞台上，与她著名的亲戚卡特家族一起唱歌，并与欧内斯特·塔布（Ernest Tubb）开玩笑。
Years later, in 1961, the Opry was where they would meet. They were backstage, and Johnny went up to June and told her, "You and I are going to get married someday." She laughed and told him that she couldn't wait. I'm guessing that when Cash went home that night, he didn't mention this to Vivian, his wife.
多年后的1961年，奥普里正是他们相遇的地方。他们在后台，约翰尼走到琼面前告诉她，“你和我有一天会结婚的。”她笑了，告诉他她等不及了。我猜当卡什那天晚上回家时，他没向他的妻子薇薇安（Vivian）提起这件事。
Not long after that, June joined Johnny's road show and they were traveling around the country together on tour. His wife mostly stayed home, and so did her husband. But June Carter was a lady-- a solid, accomplished, well-meaning Christian professional. And no solid, well-meaning Christian pro willingly falls in love with another woman's husband, especially if he's a pill-popping speed freak like Johnny Cash was back then.
在那之后不久，琼加入了约翰尼的巡演剧团，他们一起在全国各地巡演。他的妻子大部分时间待在家里，她的丈夫也一样。但琼·卡特是一位女士——一位稳重、有成就、心地善良的基督徒职业者。而没有一个稳重、心地善良的基督徒职业者会心甘情愿地爱上别人的丈夫，尤其是如果他像当时的约翰尼·卡什那样是个吃药的药物瘾君子。
Years later, June would describe falling in love with Johnny this way. "I felt like I had fallen into a pit of fire and I was literally burning alive." So June, who had been a professional musician since she was as tall as a ukulele, called her songwriting partner, Merle Kilgore, and they wrote about June's forbidden feelings for Cash.
多年后，琼会这样描述爱上约翰尼的感觉。“我觉得自己掉进了一个火坑，我真的正在活活燃烧。”所以琼，自她像尤克里里琴那么高起就是个职业音乐人，她给她的歌曲创作搭档梅尔·基尔戈尔（Merle Kilgore）打了电话，他们写了关于琼对卡什那禁忌感情的歌。
It was a song straight out of Dante. They gave it to June's not particularly Dante-esque sister Anita, who recorded it as "Love's Ring of Fire."
那是一首直接出自但丁的歌。他们把它给了琼不怎么但丁的妹妹安妮塔（Anita），她把它录制成了《爱的火环》（Love's Ring of Fire）。
[SINGING} Love is a burning thing and it makes a fiery ring. Bringing hurt to the heart's desire, I fell in the ring of fire. I fell into, into the burning ring of fire. I fell down, down, down, down, into the deepest mire. And it burns, burns, burns, burns, the ring of fire. The ring of fire. The ring of fire.
[歌唱] 爱是一种燃烧的东西，它形成了一个火环。给心中的渴望带来痛苦，我掉进了火环。我掉进了，掉进了燃烧的火环。我掉下去，掉下去，掉下去，掉进最深的泥潭。它燃烧，燃烧，燃烧，燃烧，那个火环。那个火环。那个火环。
Johnny Cash heard Anita Carter's record, and then one night, he had a dream. He dreamed of mariachi horns playing this song. Some say it was the influence of the then-popular Tijuana Brass. Others say it was the barbiturates he took before bed to take the edge off the amphetamines. Either way, Johnny cash went into the studio with a couple of trumpet players and made his dream come true.
约翰尼·卡什听了安妮塔·卡特的唱片，然后有一天晚上，他做了一个梦。他梦见墨西哥流浪乐队（mariachi horns）吹奏这首歌。有人说这是当时流行的蒂华纳铜管乐队的影响。其他人说这是他在睡前为了减轻安非他命影响而服用的巴比妥类药物。无论如何，约翰尼·卡什带着几位小号手进了录音室，让他的梦想成真了。
[SINGING] Love is a burning thing, and it makes a fiery ring.
[歌唱] 爱是一种燃烧的东西，它形成了一个火环。
The peculiarity of the song's orchestration is topped only by the weirdness of its credits. Here was a married man singing a song written about him by the betrothed woman who was in love with him, and singing the record back-up "oohs" were said woman, June Carter, as well as her sister and her mother. Mother Maybelle Carter, the most respectable elder in the history of country music, if not America itself. Listen to how cheerful they sound.
这首歌编曲的奇特性只有它名单的怪异程度能与之媲美。这里有一个已婚男人唱着由他心爱且爱着他的未婚女人为他写的歌，而为这张唱片进行“噢”伴唱的正是那位女人，琼·卡特，以及她的妹妹和母亲。梅贝尔·卡特母亲（Mother Maybelle Carter），乡村音乐史上、甚至美国历史上最受尊敬的长辈。听听她们听起来有多快乐。
[SINGING] I fell into a burning ring of fire. I went down, down, down, and the flames went higher. And it burns, burns burns, the ring of fire, the ring of fire.
[歌唱] 我掉进了一个燃烧的火环。我掉下去，掉下去，火焰烧得更高。它燃烧，燃烧，燃烧，那个火环，那个火环。
In this song, to compare love to fire, isn't just the pop music sexy heat cliche like "you give me fever" or "hunka, hunka burning love" or "it's getting hot in here." This is fire as in brimstone, old-time religion, written by the daughter of a people who believed in the eternal flames of hell.
在这首歌里，将爱比作火，不仅仅是像“你给了我发烧”或者“嗯嗯，燃烧的爱”或者“这里变得热起来了”这种流行音乐里的性感热度陈词滥调。这是硫磺般的火，古老的宗教，由一个相信地狱永恒火焰的人的女儿写的。
June Carter was coveting her neighbor's spouse, which meant she was breaking one of the Ten Commandments. Loving Johnny Cash was a sin, and for her, the wages of sin were death-- a death in which the sinner spent all eternity as nothing more than kindling.
琼·卡特在觊觎邻居的配偶，这意味着她在违背十诫之一。爱上约翰尼·卡什是种罪过，而对她来说，罪的代价就是死亡——一种罪人永恒的时间里只剩下柴火般的死亡。
When June Carter admitted to herself that she loved Johnny Cash, it is, in a small Country and Western love song way, not unlike the moment Huck Finn resolves to help the slave Jim escape, even though he's been told that doing so would be wrong. "All right then," he says. "I'll go to hell."
当琼·卡特向自己承认她爱约翰尼·卡什时，这在某种小型乡村音乐爱情歌的方式中，与哈克·费恩（Huck Finn）决定帮助奴隶吉姆（Jim）逃跑的时刻没有区别，尽管他被告知这样做是不对的。“那好吧，”他说，“那我就去地狱吧。”
This is from June's recording of "Ring of Fire." Notice, no trumpets. Just an old-timey fiddle, and she strums her autoharp, maybe ribbing her husband a little by pointing out in the liner notes, "That's the way I've heard it from the beginning."
这是来自琼录制的《火环》。注意，没有小号。只有一把老式的琴，她弹奏着她的自奏琴，也许通过在内页说明中指出“这就是我从一开始听到的方式”来稍微调侃一下她的丈夫。
[SINGING] The taste of love is sweet when hearts like ours meet. I fell for you like a child. Oh, but the fire went wild.
[歌唱] 当像我们这样的心相遇时，爱的滋味是甜的。我像个孩子一样为你沦陷。哦，但火势变狂了。
There's an acre of misgiving in that little word, "oh." As in, oh, what have I done. Oh, his poor wife. Oh, Lord, forgive me. Oh, for crying out loud, I better flush his pills down the toilet yet again. Oh, I am Grand Ole Opry royalty, and this belligerent drug addict is about to get banned from my beloved Opry for smashing out the stage lights with a mike stand, and oh, I'm going to love him anyway.
在那句小小的“哦”字里，有一英亩的懊悔。就像，哦，我做了什么。哦，他可怜的妻子。哦，主啊，原谅我。哦，大声哭出来，我最好再把他的药冲进马桶里。哦，我是大奥普里剧院的女王，而这个好战的毒瘾者即将因为用麦克风架砸碎舞台灯光而被我心爱的奥普里封杀，哦，我还是要爱他。
"Ring of Fire" became a number one hit for Johnny Cash in 1963. Then, finally, he got divorced, and June got divorced, and he got sober, and in 1968 they got married.
《火环》在1963年成为约翰尼·卡什的一首冠军单曲。然后，最终，他离婚了，琼也离婚了，他戒了毒，在1968年他们结婚了。
When I say that Johnny Cash and June Carter Cash's romance was the greatest love story of the 20th century, I'm not just thinking about their fiery courtship, though your better love stories do require that obstacles are overcome, and the Cashs had plenty of those. I was really thinking about their marriage-- 35 years of actual happily ever after.
当我说约翰尼·卡什和琼·卡特·卡什的浪漫是20世纪最伟大的爱情故事时，我不仅是在思考他们炽热的求爱，尽管你们更好的爱情故事确实需要克服障碍，而卡什夫妇有很多那种障碍。我其实是在想他们的婚姻——35年真正的从此幸福快乐。
The pictures of the two of them together through the years are almost suspiciously entertaining to look at. Johnny's cracking June up, or she's cracking him up, or in my favorite, the photo on his compilation album, Love , she's fallen asleep against his shoulder. His chin is resting on her head, and he might be smelling her hair. In his liner notes next to that picture, Johnny Cash says that he's sitting there thinking about Robert Browning's poem about the death of his wife Elizabeth Barrett Browning, when June Carter Cash walks in and wonders what he'd like to eat for lunch.
多年来他们俩在一起的照片看起来几乎是令人怀疑的有趣。约翰尼让琼大笑，或者她让他大笑，或者在我最喜欢的，他精选集《爱》（Love）的封面上，她靠在他的肩膀上睡着了。他的下巴抵在她的头上，他可能在闻她的头发。在那张照片旁边的内页说明里，约翰尼·卡什说他正坐在那里思考罗伯特·勃朗宁关于他妻子伊丽莎白·巴雷特·勃朗宁去世的诗，这时琼·卡特·卡什走进来，想知道他午饭想吃什么。
And that seems about right-- the two of them in a room together, pondering sandwiches and poetry. Grandly, he often credited her with saving his life. But he also bragged, she likes the same kind of movies I do.
这看起来差不多——他们俩在房间里，考虑着三明治和诗歌。宏大地，他经常把拯救他生命归功于她。但他也吹嘘，她喜欢和我看一样的电影。
On June's solo album, Press On , after her "Ring of Fire," the very next song is a duet with Johnny. It's a gospel ballad narrated by an old married couple worried that one will die before the other. Worried about getting left behind. "If it proves to be as well that I am first to cross," June sings, "and somehow I have a feeling it will be."
在琼的个人专辑《坚持》（Press On）中，在她的《火环》之后，紧接着的一首歌是与约翰尼的二重唱。这是一首福音民谣，由一对老夫妻叙述，担心一个会比另一个先死。担心被抛在后面。“如果事实证明我先跨越是神的旨意，”琼唱道，“不知怎么的，我有种感觉会是这样。”
[SINGING] But if it proves to be his will that I am first to cross, and somehow I've a feeling it will be. When it comes your time to travel, likewise don't feel lost. For I will be the first one that you'll see.
[歌唱] 但如果事实证明这是神的旨意，我先跨越，不知怎么的，我有种感觉会是这样。当你旅行的时间到了，同样不要感到迷失。因为我会是你看到的第一个人。
And I'll be waiting on the far side banks of Jordan. I'll be sitting, drawing pictures in the sand. And when I see you coming, I will rise up with a shout and come running through the shallow water, reaching for your hand.
我将在约旦河的远岸等待。我会坐着，在沙地上画画。当我看到你走过来，我会带着欢呼起身，跑过浅水，向你伸出手。
As she predicted in the song, June died first. Four months later, Johnny was buried next to her, because, as he once said, "This thing between us has been happening since 1961, and I just don't want to travel if she can't come with me."
正如她在歌中所预测的那样，琼先去世了。四个月后，约翰尼被埋在她旁边，因为正如他曾经说过的，“我们之间这事从1961年就开始了，如果她不能和我一起，我只是不想旅行。”
[SINGING] So I'll just rest here on the shore and turn my eyes away until you come and we'll see paradise."
[歌唱] 所以我会在这里休息，转过头去，直到你走过来，我们就会看到天堂。”
Sarah Vowell has got a brand new book, Assassination Vacation, that comes out in April.
萨拉·沃威尔有一本全新的书，《暗杀假期》（Assassination Vacation），四月份出版。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Stacy Tiderington.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我自己制作，还有黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和斯塔莉·基恩（Starlee Kine）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。 Todd Bachmann和Stacy Tiderington提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is officially our boss, but really, at this point, after all these years, he's more like a co-worker, and he's my friend. And his dad just died this week, and all of our hearts go out to him, and his mom, and his family. We'll resume making fun of him in a week or two.
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他正式是我们的老板，但实际上，到了这个时候，这么多年过去了，他更像是我的同事，而且是我的朋友。他的父亲这周刚刚去世，我们所有人的心都与他、他的母亲和他的家人同在。我们会在一两周后恢复取笑他的习惯。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。